reality is is that the world is not so
black and white so I understand that
there are these things in place that
worked and made sense and now we're
approaching an era that like we don't
know what's going to happen but there's
gray area you've had sex I've had sex
she's had sex we've had sex with
different guys that doesn't mean that
we're damaged goes we're used Goods I
understand status is a big part of that
I understand that sex is view
differently but I feel like you should
not if you're if you're looking at face
value I can understand why you would be
judged from your past but if if I'm a
guy interested in you I don't care about
what you've done